Is there something to help bring up white blood cells and red blood cell codes after chemo?
Well, your red blood cell codes are beat up after chemo because chemo just kills everything. That's the problem and really the only thing that's gonna really help with that is
You know doing an I heard and
And
vitamin B12
Your white blood cell codes bring it up white blood cell
Is all your immune stimulants so everything that you're currently taking is an immune stimulant which is so many things on your protocol
You know just keep
pushing those
To build that up make sure you're getting rest for sure
That's important to get your white blood cell contact too
Which are not stressing yourself. So think about adaptogens to help with stress after chemo 2
And we just running your right. There isn't a mute stimulant program on the right
that I
Tell
You know that I have it in your
Overnight programs so you can run that. I don't think it's a long program. I look for a mute
Stimulation, I think it's called
You know just keep pushing those. You know just keep pushing those. You know just keep pushing those.